here on finland's eastern border finns
live nearer to russia st petersburg than
their own capital helsinki
geographically close they've rarely felt
more politically distant from their
neighbor
russia has been to this area both a
blessing and a curse
of course we depend very much upon the
trade
with russia but then on the other hand
there is this part of russia that is
very very bad
and this is the border here now so
we're looking now into russia
born and bred up by the border with
russia for years rita backed finland's
neutrality
then president putin invaded ukraine and
suddenly being in nato seemed like a
much safer bet
you live right near the russian border
are you worried that if you join nato
russia could turn its aggression to you
that is why we are joining nato
yeah that's the reason why
because we need more power you see
russia is a country that respects only
power nothing else a power needs a
counterpower now we will have it with
nato
as a result of that
we have today a historic day
finland's
not
everything has available when russia
attacked ukraine and i personally think
that we cannot trust
anymore that there will be peaceful
future
next to russia
with our own that's why we're making the
decisions to joining nato it's act of
peace that there would ever again be war
in finland
i have written a book
from my childhood
seppo remembers the last battle with the
then soviet union as a child he saw the
bombs dropping
he knows a nato application will rattle
the russians i'm not worried
relations are now very bad with putin's
government but
they are not so bad that they made a
attack here you know i don't think so
i'm not afraid but i'm sad
but possible russian retaliation could
mean more economic pain
covert and the war in ukraine have
already hit these frontier areas hard
russian tourism has dwindled
now traffic trickles through checkpoints
maria is one of around 80 000 russians
living in finland she's furious with
president putin i think he's a terrorist
because of him invading ukraine
of course and because he is flushing all
the russia
through in the toilet
into the toilet
it's all his uh
he hates russians he hates all the
nations
he's killing the russia he's not a
patriot really
what's happening here is a monumental
shift for a country with a tradition of
staying out of alliances the war in
ukraine has crossed a line
people here are now embracing joining
nato
today finland has changed the course of
its own future and the future of
security across europe siobhan robbins
sky news finland